[Musique]
dans le cadre de l'association sportive
de l'établissement de l'urss
nous portons un projet je porte un
projet en direction du népal pour donc
23 élèves donc de jeunes en situation de
handicap dans le cadre de l'inclusion et
donc qui appartient enfin qui sont pas
là lèvent pas ayem de la l'espace et
donc nous faisons notre départ ce soir
en direction du népal pour un trek de 12
jours et avec l'ambition de d'emmener le
plus grand nombre d'élèves sur un sommet
qui est à 4990 m de sergo riz est au
nord-est katmandou dans une vallée qui
s'appelle la vallée du langtang est donc
dans ce projet sportif on a également
plusieurs projets
humanitaire et solidaire donc on va
monter un cabinet d'optique provisoire
dans des villages dans quatre villages
que l'on va traverser
donc des élèves vont faire passer des
tests optiques à la population nous
amenons 800 lunettes de vue avec nous et
nous avons un opticien qui rêve un pièce
de venir nous accompagner et donc on va
essayer de donner des lunettes adaptées
meilleure acuité visuelle possible au
ces personnes donc on a ce premier
projet ensuite on a un autre projet ou
les enfants de l'ime sont intégrés
puisque on a 27 four solaire que dans la
fabrique et au lycée professionnel
lepervanche de la possession et donc ses
fours solaires sont déjà arrivés à
capendu depuis deux ans grâce à aviation
sans frontières qui nous a aidés dans ce
dans ce projet et on va remonter ses 27
four solaire dans des familles
dans des villages que l'on va qui seront
identifiés par la fondation sayous wii
qui avec qui on travaille en partenariat
donc on n'est pas là et ensuite on a eu
un dernier groupe de chanteurs on entend
un petit peu là en couverture derrière
et un petit groupe de six sept élèves
qui sont des anciens élèves du collège
beaulieu qui sont maintenant tous en
lice et puisque le projet a duré cinq
ans et donc dans les villages ils vont
proposer des chants des danses moringue
maloya de la vie de la réunion la
réunion les larmes voilà
savoir qu'elle va vivre cette riche
expérience voilà
ce voyage qui va être
basso monsieur magnifique magique
voilà on est fier et je remercie toute
l'équipe pédagogique monsieur renard
d'avoir organisé un tel voyage
aujourd'hui mais il est très content
parce que le projet concrétise enfin
depuis 2010 est ça commence à ela lab a
banni pense que va permettre à d'autres
de voir un petit peu comment ça se passe
de responsabilisation basera grandi
comme c'est un projet humanitaire voire
même des dînettes et tout donc vois la
vie autrement
goncourt j'ai vu nos moutons mais c'est
une possibilité mais connu le jeu doit
on a mis beaucoup de choses
ja nouveau culture bar bars où en est ma
nièce nouveau regard
au moins bon dieu